c'est l'abbé louis denoit l'année jetant
son corps
cette chanson mythique date de 1946 mais
vous la connaissez tous
avant de fermer les paupières
petit papa noël de tino rossi a traversé
les époques pour devenir le symbole de
noël e type panneaux
écrite par raymond vincy et composé par
henri martin et le petit papa noël a
tout de suite été un succès le père noël
de 1975 la comparer même à la
marseillaise
vous connaissez petit papa noël bien sûr
c'est l'hymne du papa noël
je pense bien que je connais et je serai
ravi de l'entendre encore une fois à
l'appel de noël c'est évident
donc cette chanson vous plaît cette
chanson me plaît maggie aimez-vous la
marseillaise bien sûr évidemment grâce à
cette chanson tino rossi devient en 1949
le premier chanteur français à obtenir
un disque d'or il est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui l'artiste français qui a
vendu le plus de disques de tous les
temps dit don pour un succès c'est un
succès oui je crois
c'est un tel succès que tin oo je crois
que c'est à toi de faire ce geste que la
maison de disque offre il faut le dire
un disque d'or henry martinet parce
qu'il a été vendu de petit papa noël il
faut dire le chiffre est incroyable 25
millions dans le monde dans des
humiliant en france chaque année près de
100 mille disques du petit papa noël
sont vendus une chanson qui a donc été
reprise limitée réinterpréter chanter
dans différentes langues
attention med les donneurs
dis papa noël
du
sommes que deux roues ou par mail à mon
petit juillet
[Musique]
tu vas voir si fois c'est un peu à cause
de moi
[Musique]